It was pointed out in the
comments for the last video,
where I defined this
insertion_sort, that I didn't
necessarily have
to do this break.
And this is one
of those examples
that sometimes when you just
program something-- in the way
that, at least, your brain
is thinking about it--
you don't always do it in
maybe the most elegant way.
And that commenter was right.
There was actually maybe
a lot more elegant way
to actually do this
insertion_sort.
So over here, if we go
into the while loop,
I have this while
loop happening while i
is greater than or equal to 0.
But then I want it to
essentially break out
of that while loop, if the
variable value is not less
than the i-th element in list.
So one way to do
this-- because really,
I'm just defining the parameters
on when to do this while loop.
Instead of doing
this if the value is
less than the i-th element,
do this and otherwise break.
What I could have done--
and this would have actually
been a more elegant
way to do this--
while i is greater than
or equal to 0 and value
is less than the
i-th element in list.
So now this is still
the same as before.
But now I know
that value is less
than the i-th
element in the list.
So I will execute
this code over here.
So I know that this
is going to be true.
Let me take all of
these one level back.
And then I don't
have to do an else.
And I don't have to break
out of the loop anymore.
And so that should simplify
the program a good bit.
But let's verify for ourselves
that this actually works.
So let me save it.
And then let me run it.
Let me define a list.
So I'll just call it c is equal
to 1, 5, 6, 7, 2, 4, 14, and 2.
So let's just define that.
And let's try our
insertion_sort.
Insertion_sort on c.
So let's see what we get.
So let's see.
Let's print c now.
And there you go.
It's sorted it.
So thank you for the comment.
I think this does
simplify it a little bit.
Sometimes you always
have to question,
especially if you have
a while statement,
is there a better way
instead of using the break.
Because that's essentially--
I'm putting a condition
on a reason to break
out of the while loop.
But why don't I implicitly
just put it up here?